un nouveau coup dur pour le monde
culturel avec des chiffres de lakovic
toujours alarmant la date de réouverture
du 7 janvier des établissements et très
vite abandonnée par le gouvernement
pas de réouverture non plus pour les
bars et les restaurants
le gouvernement ne l'envisagent pas
avant mi février la campagne de
vaccination a débuté à saint quentin en
yvelines dix volontaires ont reçu la
première injection à l'unité de soins de
longue durée du centre hospitalier de
plaisir et son état d' à versailles ce
sont les professionnels de santé de plus
de 50 ans qui sont vaccinées au sein de
l'hôpital mignot un centre a aussi
ouvert le 7 janvier à poissy son
objectif vacciner 150 personnes par jour
le divorce est acté entre l'europe et le
royaume uni depuis le 1er janvier
plusieurs entreprises yvelinois sont
touchés plus de démarches
administratives pour les imports et les
exports et des délais de livraison
rallongés
les images viennent de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique mais ont marqué les
américains vivant dans les yvelines des
partisans de donald trump ont envahi le
capitole à washington le congrès
certifié les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
pas